guatemala es un país de 18 millones de
habitantes donde el 40 por ciento de su
población es indígenas de acuerdo con la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos los pueblos indígenas de este
país centroamericanos sufren de una
fuerte discriminación y racismo que se
ve reflejado en que el 75% de ellos vive
en la pobreza la economía está muy mal
aquí en guatemala cada tiempo el
gobierno aumenta las cosas y nosotros no
ganamos mayor cosa aquí nosotros
dependemos de lo que nosotros ganamos no
tenemos otro salario o no tenemos otros
ingresos sino que solo solo depende de
lo que nosotros vendemos aquí uno de los
graves problemas que aquejan a los
pueblos indígenas en guatemala es que el
90 por ciento de sus mujeres son
analfabetas por eso muchas de ellas
esperan que sus hijas corran con otra
suerte yo pues les digo a todas las
indígenas verdad seamos orgullosas desde
tener la dicha de poder trabajar y de
salir hacia adelante y para darles un
estudio a nuestros hijos quizás nosotros
no tuvimos la oportunidad ellos tendrán
la oportunidad en el día internacional
de los pueblos indígenas la onu quiso
destacar el papel de las mujeres en la
preservación del conocimiento ancestral
pero también su rol sosteniendo a las
familias en guatemala nueve de cada diez
mujeres indígenas trabaja en el sector
informal está bien porque como las
mujeres somos las que tenemos como un
rol más importante en el hogar y en
general en todo y el hombre más que todo
es como con soporte con hombre con
nosotras somos las que bueno nosotros
también como mujeres ahora verdad
probablemente antes no se daba eso pero
ahorita ahorita las mujeres han tener un
poquito más de participación no hay de
siento que eso es bueno para nosotras
pues como indígenas según la cdh el
racismo y el machismo son estructurales
en guatemala un país que sigue ubicando
en la base de su pirámide a los pueblos
indígenas como trabajo forzado y
explotación servil un sometimiento
heredado de la colonia